[Music]
[Music]
you believe in pirates of course and you
look here you get the view that the
audience guess
[Music]
you best start believin in ghost stories
you're in one the Pirates franchises
wonderful characters caught up in this
magical fantastic world
movie about a ride in a movie that's
about pirates and the combination of
those two is just captured everybody's
imagination and became a new success
welcome to the Caribbean that
fan base for Pirates of the Caribbean
has become massive early
and Johnny as Jack Sparrow I just think
he's extraordinary he created this
fantastic character who became kind of
an icon that everybody loves
[Music]
we have such fond memories of the first
three and it's just gone making a meal
[Music]
when you watch the films you get this
feeling this sensation that anything can
happen
janice buttrum Knievel is a pirate
[Music]
his new parrots movie has new characters
as gonna bring a new flavor and a
different dimension to one of the most
powerful franchises of all time dad
taking
this movie is so fresh so different so
scary it's a whole reinvention of a
pirate's me
for its life
[Music]
pirates had infected the seas for
generations
so I felt eliminate them all
and then there was this boy get Spyro
follow him
he took everything from me
listen
reach
[Applause]
the dead I've taken command of the sea
I've heard stories
the mighty Spanish captain whose son to
be killed thousands of men no no no men
no no pirates pirates
I once knew a Spaniard named something
in Spanish
he's coming future
where's your ship the crew
your pants Jackie I'm so sorry we're
still talking there's no word hide
find spy refer me
this moment on we ought to be allies
chittering where your left hand as I
said we're more than that
monkey
[Music]
looking for trouble horrible a Nalini
you'll pay for what you did to me
middleman Chopin looking for jackets I'm
going to swim for it Karina stop this no
no no no that's okay this has gone far
enough
no it has off I saw our ankles
you'da seen a lot more of the cab you
hiked hole shot I will have my revenge
you sure you're the Jack Sparrow
first your pants a great planet